let me ask you um
about um
over medication
that we've been
talking about from different angles but
one
difficult question for me i'll just
i'll pick one of the difficult topics
depression
so depression is is a serious
painful
condition that leads to a lot of people
suffering in the world
and yet it is likely they were over
prescribing antidepressants
so as a doctor
as a patient as a healthcare system
as a society what do we do with that
fact
that
people suffer
there's a lot of people suffering
from depression
and there's also people suffering from
over prescribing of antidepressants
right
so a paper in the new england journal by
eric turner
showed that the data
if you put all the data together from
antidepressants
you find out that
antidepressants are not effective
for people who are depressed but don't
have a major depression
major depression is a serious
problem uh people can't function
normally
um
they have a hard time getting out doing
performing their
normal social roles
um but what's happened is that the
publicity i mean prozac nation
was a good example
of
making the argument that why should
people settle for normal happiness when
they can have better than normal
happiness and if you're not having
normal happiness uh you should take a
drug well
they
that concept that serotonin
metabolism is the root cause of
depression
is really a destructive one we don't we
have drugs that change serotonin
metabolism but we don't know if that's
why
uh
antidepressants work on major depression
and they don't certainly don't work on
everybody with major depression i forget
what the number needed to treat is i
think it's around four
one out of four people have significant
improvement but the people without major
depression
don't get better and the vast majority
of these drugs are used for people
without major depression
so what's happened is that the
feelings of life satisfaction of
happiness and not sadness
have been
medicalized the normal range of feelings
have been medicalized
and that's not to say that they
shouldn't be attended to
but it the evidence shows that attending
to them by giving somebody a medicine
doesn't help except that they feel like
somebody cares about them and believes
that they're suffering but there are
problems in living
that give rise to much of this
symptomatology of
less than major depression and let's
call it what it is
and figure out a way to help people
individual therapy group therapy um
maybe lifestyle modification would work
we got to try that
but let's call it what it is instead of
saying oh you're
in this vast
basket of people who are depressed so
we'll give you an antidepressant even
though the evidence shows that people
who are suffering from your level of
depression don't get better
and that's
a consequence of not
focusing on
preventative medicine the lifestyle
changes all that kind of stuff well yes
but it's really a consequence of the
drug companies creating the impression
that if you're sad take a pill
if you're
non-major depression
how do you overcome depression
well you have to talk about what the
problem
is so talk therapy
lifestyle changes well no i'm not
jumping to that i'm saying that
you ought to a
the way you feel
must be respected
yeah acknowledge that you're suffering
acknowledge that you're suffering and
deal with health care providers who
acknowledge that you're suffering so
let's take that first step
and big first step also big first step
yeah family docs are pretty good at that
that's kind of the arena that caused me
to go into family medicine
the subjective experience of the patient
okay so you're a person
who is not getting the enjoyment out of
their life that they feel they ought to
be getting now let's figure out why
and whether that means some time with a
social worker sometime with a
psychiatrist sometime with a psychiatric
nurse
i'm not sure how you'd best do that most
effectively and efficiently but that's
what you need to do
and it may be that there's um a marital
problem and there's something going on
and
one of the spouses can't find
satisfaction in the life they have to
live within the relationship maybe
there's a past history of trauma or
abuse that somebody is projecting onto
their current situation
uh maybe the socioeconomic circumstances
where they can't find a job that gives
them self-respect and enough money to
live
all you know
an infinite range of things but let's
figure out make a diagnosis first the
diagnosis isn't that the person feels
sadder than they feel
than they want to feel
the diagnosis is why does the person
feel sadder than they want to feel
you